parallèlement au baccalauréat s'est
ouvert la saison des concours aux
grandes écoles certains jeunes très doux
et très travailleur aussi n'hésitent pas
à passer plusieurs de ces examens pour
entrer dans l'école la plus prestigieuse
cette école est bien elle porte un nom
c'est polytechnique clope aux danses qui
daniel les filles élise joue aujourd'hui
son avenir
à 19 ans elle passe le concours de
polytechnique elle s'apprête à flancher
quatre heures sur la discipline reine
les mathématiques
une épreuve régler avec une rigueur
toute militaire pour en arriver là
elise a suivi deux années de classes
préparatoires ma dessus et matt fait au
lycée louis le grand à paris où un
étudiant sur trois intègre l'x ses
infinies et évidemment l'existence de la
solution du roi 0 pour la valeur était
tout simplement l'énoncé du terrain de
jeu suivi il existe évidemment une elise
comme ses camarades présente plusieurs
concours à la fois les mines centrale et
l'école normale supérieure
les grosses têtes des bêtes à concours
des mots qui agace ça m'énerve ce sont
deux bêtes à concours parce que ce ne
sont pas des médias concours sont des
gens qui travaillent et puis je tirais
qu'effectivement il n'est pas à l'heure
actuelle dit un plaisir de dire qu'on ne
travaille pas c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai si on veut réussir on travaille
bien qu'un terne
elle ne sacrifie pas ses loisirs je
pense que c'est important quand de
déterminer ses activités à côté parce
que il faut quand même pouvoir se
détendre trop longtemps et puis on
puisse changer les idées quoi les avoir
la tête ailleurs c'est impossible jour
du concours fou le temps est minuté
vous amenez vous poser le stylo vous
restez beaucoup plus simple à
l'intérieur de la copie double on va
venir formaté poursuit fin de l'épreuve
l'appréciation est mitigé en cas de coup
dur
et tout ça marcherait parce que sa
nouveauté si ça marche il était très
fatigué mais bon je sais pas trop si
c'est un marché quoi on peut pas
vraiment savoir j'ai fait des trucs mais
sur 3000 candidats
on ne compte que 15 % de filles les
épreuves se poursuivent encore un mois
résultat en juillet